who's the big boss this guy Anthony
DeVito over here yeah
[Laughter]
what's your last name what Italian or
Greek
my God yo you got so much greasy Italian
Vibe coming off of you I've never seen
so many stereotypical Italians running a
tech business in my life what do you
mean why because the tech business
should look like this yeah Mr Ragusa
thanks for inviting your Indian staff
hey he can't they're in India
getting paid 30 rupees for every [__]
hour they're working I'm gonna tell you
right now
this seems this seems like such a front
you know I've ever seen a business yeah
everybody's got the Saint Anthony
Medallion underneath their shirt it's
ridiculous yeah yeah
if someone hacks you guys you just go
break their legs physically just
Tracer right IP and [__] you just got
Ragusa